[Music]
my heart is gold but my regime is
pattern she's been the breakout star of
Nick vile season of The Bachelor but is
Corinne as sexual and bold as she seems
et caught up with Nick at ABC's
Television Critics Association party I
think so far her portrayals accurate as
far as Corinne she had the big
personality and she's certainly not
afraid to take risks I think you're
seeing a little bit of that at the same
times there's a like like there is for
all of us I think we all have a lot of
different personalities a lot different
sides to us and I think I appreciate the
fact that over time people have gotten
to see more of me and they've been
patient with me and I hope they are as
patient with the fruit as they have been
with me dad would be proud even though I
was naked he would be proud and of
course Nick wouldn't fess up on whether
he ends up engaged on the show but do
tell us this about the outcome
I'm excited I've certainly no regrets
and it'll be fun to watch it unfold and
and the intimacy bachelor nation what
they think about it efforts
you